you know skim it and just have a
conversation I'm like no I want to read
this whole book it's really fascinating
I want to get a read any other scratch
cooks I'm gonna get a feel for the
scratch cooks and the Nissan profs oh we
got some grants gonna get it can I get
some hands off his cash me some floss
all right please say okay my tribe is
much smaller I see that in black yeah
that's drinking though okay we'll talk
about that so I don't know gosh you you
have some slides are they looping right
now they're looping slides so what
you're seeing is you're seeing some
snippets from some of the interesting
personalities that I've collected in
this book just real quickly the first
person you saw was Samuel Francis he was
the steward for President Washington and
you probably saw that picture in like he
looks a lot like a white dude and there
was a lot of heated debate among
scholars about his race but a quite a
few of his descendants believe that he
was biracial and then he had african
heritage i show hercules who was the
enslaved cook for george washington who
also escaped successfully on george
washington's 65th birthday he's not the
only famous escape now famous right we
know about Oney judge as well right who
actually escaped before him I was
curious if one was inspired by the other
right so she escapes before a few years
before hercules does and what's
interesting about the portrait you see
is that is actually a portrait that is
hanging in a museum in madrid spain and
the title of the portrait is a cook for
george washington and the painter is
Gilbert Stuart the same guy who did the
iconic portrait of George Washington
what's interesting about that portrait
is the chef's outfit that Hercules has
is one that would be worn by a European
chef not an American chef at that time
seeing what happened with Oni judge and
knowing how vindictive George Washington
goes was and I you read the letters of
Washington's reaction and the extent to
which he tries to get Hercules after he
escapes do you think of that song from
frozen you know let it go he could not
let it go
so it makes sense that Hercules goes
overseas because that was probably the
safest thing for him to do he was able
to do that as you document because he
actually made money selling scraps of
food that was interesting because as a
food historian I've come across that but
I the story as you know in food history
there are stories and then there are
facts in history and sometimes they are
hard to discern but we I had learned
that he sold he he was such a great cook
that people he was in demand that he was
able to sell meals and stuff to people
but this piece about the scraps what was
that about I mean that was part of the
same thing so trash it sounded like a
lot of a lot of chefs personal chefs
sometimes the employer would give them
the liberties to sell the scraps and
slops because people would use them to
make candles or you know they would
repurpose those things see leaves from
inside of tht bad right so but Hercules
this brothers cooking was so good he
made about five thousand dollars a year
and you know twenty fifteen dollars in
terms of what he was selling and so he
would actually buy fancy clothes he had
a gold cane and Washington gave him a
lot of liberties so after he was done
working he would just put on that blue
suit with the gold cane and walk around
Philadelphia he was allowed to go to the
Opera so he had quite a few liberties
and that sells a whole lot about
nonetheless he was trying to be free I
mean this whole mythology which you also
touched on about the happy slave and the
propaganda around that - in society to
make people believe slavery wasn't so
bad right and you know with all these
liberties and perks and and whatever you
know he still was like I'm out right and
you know he believed he does make his
way he books Passage to Spain well
that's one what's one theory they don't
know exactly where he ends up but the
clothing is a clue but nobody knows for
sure and the interesting thing is
towards the end well there's a couple
things first of all when Washington
brings Hercules to Philadelphia to be
his cook he does this after for six
months he had a white woman named mrs.
Reid and he wasn't feeling her cooking
at all and so he brings Hercules from
the Mount Vernon kitchen to come to
Philadelphia but the tricky thing was
that Philadelphia at something called
the gradual abolition act of said
1880 so if you were an enslaved person
in Philadelphia or in Pennsylvania soil
at that time if you were there for six
months you are automatically free so
what Washington would do to get around
this is that right about that time the
six months would toll he would pack up
all the enslaved people and send them
back to Mount Vernon keep them there for
a few weeks and then bring him blood
back to start the clock over again and
he did this throughout his - I know
crazy right he did this throughout his
two terms but for some reason towards
the end of his second term he sends
Hercules back not to the Mount Vernon
kitchen but into the fields to make
bricks and do other hard labor and that
is what really spurs hercule to make the
dash for freedom but yet after he
escapes after Hercules escapes
Washington writes these letters like oh
my cook is gone I can't I need my cook
back I can't in the house and fall apart
you know we can't live if you read the
letters in sequence he's going through
the five stages of grief I really
believe that there's a lot in here a lot
of and then the letters from Martha
Washington I mean to me it reads like
something you would see on the real
housewives of old Virginia just the way
she convinced me right thanks for
laughing at that joke I worked hard on
that one drama but you know he had put
him out in the field I guess that was a
punishment but you know I wonder if
Hercules knew that it was a punishment
or maybe that's what spurred him to be
like I am out of here you know it seems
to be the precipitating event is that
Washington suspected that Hercules was
going to escape with at least some of
his family members one of his sons was
caught stealing money out of a kind of a
backpack and it was believed that that
was going to finance an escape attempt
so I think that's what precipitated it
before we move on to the other very
important person we're going to talk
about after Hercules um I thought it
really interesting this character who
was George Washington's step grandson
nephew whatever sees how he actually
luckily for you and for us for the sake
of this research documents in detail
about Hercules his artistry and talent
and and all that what was that about it
sound like I'm early bromance or
something where he's just going on and
on about you know yeah so she did so
George Washington Park Custis is
Washington step grandson and just
admires Washington so he thanks to him
the diary that he kept and the
observations that he made we get a sense
of Hercules personality and what he had
going on in the kitchen so one thing to
know is that Hercules had us a biracial
staff he had enslaved African I'll say
racial and biracial right in black yeah
so he had enslaved Africans from Mount
Vernon and there were indentured White's
that worked in the kitchen and then his
boss was a biracial man Samuel Francis
that I talked about so they were all in
the kitchen together but evidently
Hercules was quite temperamental as a
chef so I think he would feel a kinship
with Gordon Ramsay but because this
talks about the servants flying at his
instructions and if they messed up how
he would kind of go off on them another
interesting person who's shown up here
is a woman named Laura okay so well he's
not really a presidential chef but one
is James Hemings he does cook for a
president he cookies Thomas Jefferson's
chef before he becomes president correct
but he does cook for Jefferson that
summer of 1801 in March in Monticello
not in the right executive house right
right so James Hemings was one of Sally
Hemings older brothers when James was 19
and Jefferson gets appointed to become
minister of France he actually takes
Hemings over to France with him and for
three years has hymns trained as a
classical French chef and spends a lot
of money to do this and he installs
Hemmings as his chef de cuisine he
didn't pay him before for being in slave
right yeah well he doesn't but when he
after he finishes this training he
actually starts paying Hemmings and so
he installs him as the chef de cuisine
at the residence in Paris and brings him
back and so he's here in Philadelphia
but then in as you know in the mid 1790
hemming says I want to be free and
Jefferson agrees to do this on two
conditions
one you have to teach other enslaved
people at Monticello how to cook because
I spent all this money training you I
want you to impart that knowledge and to
you have to leave behind your recipes
and Hemings does this and then he's
freed and on February 5th 1796 what you
see rolling through here is you're gonna
see a list of all the kitchen utensils
that were at Monticello and that is
written in Hemings own hand and that's
at the Library of Congress if you ever
want to see that yeah he was literate
not only English but also French because
he did study it when he got there and as
novella had mentioned earlier I'm one of
the cofounders of the James Hemings
foundation which you can learn more
about online and I believe one of our
other co-founders is here when it gave
her a shout-out yeah she's right here
come on in the house so yes I want to
make sure we talked about James because
yeah he he's that you know you'd also
talk about this whole interplay between
French cooks and French culinary
technique and african-american cookery
and the fusion of Virginia and French
and and research shows that James is the
first maybe not the only over time but
maybe the only who actually trains in
France for this you know chef de cuisine
status right and so and the reason why I
included him in the book is one because
several reasons one he has a fascinating
story but also I think he just set the
tone for presidential cooking at least
through Jefferson's presidency now what
happens is that two enslaved women from
Monticello end up being assistant chefs
in the kitchen to a Frenchman honorary
Julian and the reason why i Hemings
doesn't become chef is he actually
drinks himself to death in 1801 so so
the story goes so the story goes yeah
president president principal founder
Asheville chef McElveen will be on site
in a fellowship starting next week in
Monticello there's some new you alluded
to this about the existing documentation
but there's new information that
surfacing that we believe will provide
more dimension to
to James's story okay buddy but he does
he dies he dies so we have we have to
enslave women who are working in the
White House kitchen and they after
Jefferson's presidency they are the main
cooks at Monticello essentially
entrapped in the yeah you talk about
them being trapped in the base right so
typically the White House and anybody
who's been in Washington DC in July and
August will understand that this but
typically during the summer the White
House had a skeleton crew because it's
built in a swamp it's in a reclaimed
swamp and people in the White House
kitchen would actually get tropical
diseases but for whatever reason
Jefferson would not let those two women
go back to their families when he would
leave the White House during summer
breaks so they actually had to stay
there and we see examples of the
husband's back at Monticello escaping
trying to reunite with their wives and
Jefferson catching them before they even
get to the White House and returning
them so that just gives you a but their
life was pretty much in the White House
basement there were slave quarters right
off the main kitchen they lived there
they slept there the floors would flood
when it rained and it was hot and the
fire and we have to remember they're
cooking from hearth cookery not modern
ranges that you can oven you can preheat
and turn off and these fires would roar
constantly and and and that hearth
cooking there was a there was a
fireplace with a range on top but there
was a fire there was another fireplace
that was open hearth cooking like that
and according to some sources injuries
related to Hart cooking were the second
leading cause of injury to women in the
1800's in 1700 and 1800 next to
pregnancy so I just seriously shows you
how dangerous that work was absolutely
yeah I mean we can only imagine there's
long hot iron rods and no pot holders
and no ice right so yeah that I love how
you I love how you you know have stories
within stories like the story about the
husbands who were trying to see their
wives and and how you learn history
along the way which which is great for
those of us who prefer to learn history
through the lens of not just food but
from the black perspective I love how
you have actual quotes from the people
who have worked and cooked and served
some of these presidents you want to
talk about some of the personalities of
the dynamic between the presidents and
and some of the people who serve them
sure so there are really three main
themes to the book one is just to show
how these African Americans were
culinary artists the second is to show
how they were family confidants in many
situations and then the third is
unwittingly or sometimes consciously
they were often civil rights advocates
when civil right when african-american
civil rights advocates could not an
activist couldn't get access to the
President to lay out their agenda they
would often go to the cook and ask the
cook to just whisper in his ear while
they were serving him food hoping that
something would register and the
president would move on it but one of
the funniest stories is involves zephyr
right zephyr right was the longtime
private cook for Lyndon Johnson and her
story is fascinating and of all the
cooks that I discussed in the book she's
the one I would love to just sit down
and have dinner with her and just talk
about her experience but she was key to
the 1964 Civil Rights Act because when
Johnson was lobbying that bill with
members of Congress he would use her Jim
Crow experiences back then the family
would drive from Texas to Washington DC
and Zephyr Wright would write along with
the family and in many instances she was
not allowed to go to the bathroom or eat
with the family and she suffered so many
indignities that because she couldn't go
into the restaurant right they were
stopping at along the way right yeah so
she suffered so many indignities that at
some point she just diffused to go on
the trip so she lived in Washington here
around so the president would often say
it's a shame that my cook has to go
through this so after he signs that bill
he presents her with one of the pins and
says you deserve this as much as anyone
now one of the things that we know about
LBJ's personality and so he would often
show up late for dinner and demand to
have food right away and she would just
say well you just go sit in the kitchen
and wait while I make something and he
would do it another thing is that he
would often show up late with guests and
want dinner made you know he would show
up at 10 o'clock with six guests so
Zephyr right strategy was she would
start making the food but she would just
send out drinks and nobody ever
complained but one thing is just to show
how she's an interesting figure and
plays a role in the perception that the
president has in terms of food is there
something that I call the great chili
controversy of 1964 yeah so every once
in a while the White House will put out
a recipe of for food and there was a
recipe for too good the press yet just
to put it out there and there was a
recipe for something called perdón Ellis
River chili and this was a river that
runs along the LBJ Ranch in Central
Texas now is anybody here from Texas
anybody know about Texas chili all right
Texas chili is distinctive in this sense
it has no beans because its chili con
carne right chili peppers with meat not
chili con frijoles so when this recipe
comes out Americans freak out and they
want to be assured that their president
loves beans and so other exact things
but big once upon a time they went off
so in the in the Johnson library because
he was he used the recording system in
the Oval Office pretty extensively and
had other phone calls recorded as well
so it starts out with Kennedy in terms
of the recording system then Johnson and
really ramps it up and then he
recommends it to Nixon and we know how
that turned out
so if we if you'll indulge me for a
moment I actually have a clip from the
Johnson library of Zephyr right talking
about the president's Beene preferences
so if we could play that clip the first
voice you're gonna hear is Juanita
Roberts who was Johnson's social
secretary and so she's the one getting
all of this flak from the public and
then you're gonna hear is that for right
if we can play that
what's that
okay
it's not gonna play okay all right could
you give me the book
all right I will that's all right all
right yeah okay so what I did is I
actually transcribed this recipe in the
book or this conversation in the book so
I'll just go ahead and read it all right
so they get in the first voice you're
gonna hear is Juanita Roberts's want me
to do money too I'm kidding no that's
all right I won't do a dramatic
interpretation on Jude so it says we
have correspondents asking up at the
president and the first family like
beans
well I know enough to say yes but I
wanted to check with you what would you
say if you were asked that question by a
responsible person right answers oh I
would say yes and Robert says and they
didn't ask what kind did they know but I
know that he particularly likes pork and
beans
he likes pork and beans he likes pinto
beans he likes lima beans green beans
and that's green lime azar dried green
lyma's green mm-hmm and the green fresh
green beans and he liked the Blue Lake
canned green beans you know the
marinated and use it in a salad
marinated and French dressing and he
likes well that's not a bean though it's
a pea I started to say green peas but he
just like beans now the green lyma's the
baby lime is the green light baby lima
is how do you prepare those for him oh
just in salty water cook them and add a
little oleo margarine and pepper and
cook them for a good long while until
the juice in them is kind of thick yes
you use the Velveeta don't you well I do
that for parties we use the Velveeta
also mushrooms you know we call it lima
beans with cheese and mushroom sauce and
the pinto beans I guess cook like cook
like I do with salt pork and ham bone
that's right
the pork and beans do you doctor them up
no not for him he just likes them plain
he doctored them himself with some kind
of pepper sauce or something like that
all right Zephyr do you know where any
of the chili cards are the chili recipe
cards mm-hmm I sure don't I may have one
or two here well somebody's got one and
I'll find it because I need that one
also okay nice talking to you okeydoke
thank you a lot bye so Velveeta for
special occasions only the best right
but it's a it's a great and if I believe
if you get the audiobook you actually
can get that tape audiobook you could
have sent me instead of me staying up
all night
I have to be specific all right yeah so
I just think that's a fun conversation
so it just shows how when the lighthouse
goes into spin control they go to her
another couple of stories I want to tell
is involves cooks for Franklin Roosevelt
right with Franklin Franklin Roosevelt
yeah so the White House food reputation
during Franklin Roosevelt's
administration was horrible
tell everybody what year that I mean you
know smart people yeah 1933 - so the
problem was is that Eleanor Roosevelt
was fundamentally uninterested in food
and for much of our presidential history
the first lady usually had an active
hand in the food operations because they
she knew what her husband liked it would
just make sure that what her husband
wanted and needed was what happened now
also she's the one that would save the
president from themselves because often
presidents would like to stray from the
diet and get comfort food in junk food
but Eleanor Roosevelt seeds this - a
woman named Henrietta Nesbit who she
meets in New York while FDR's governor
and Henry Anna Nesbit just basically
couldn't cook out what thing the Foods
assistant no she wasn't a sister she was
a white white woman now the one thing
that broad bothered me is that you had
this team of african-american cooks who
she supervised something and they had to
put something good out but what we find
out from memoirs is that Henrietta
Nesbit would go stand behind them and
correct the seasoning I heard about this
yeah just mess everything up
it was so bad y'all that when people got
invited to a state dinner at the White
House they often ate before they went
dad yeah so two cooks that I talked
about one was named Lizzy McDuffie who
was really a maid but she would help out
with the food sometimes and there was a
woman named Daisy Bonner who cooked for
Roosevelt when he would go to Warm
Springs Georgia for treatments for his
polio because unlike his wife he
appreciated absolutely yeah okay so he
would go for two to three weeks at a
time and a wealthy family in Warm
Springs a wealthy wife family loaned
their African American cook to him this
woman named Daisy Bonner so if the first
lady and the White House physician were
with them they knew that the food was
going to be great because it was going
to be something that's adhered to a diet
so Bonner and McDuffie would look at the
president and decide whether he was Peak
it or not Peak it yes you know looking
pale not looking healthy and if he was
peaking what they would do is they would
bring the food out that the first lady
or the doctor prescribed right and they
would as they were putting the plate by
him they would whisper in his ear don't
eat that FDR would fake like he wasn't
hungry he would play around with his
food and then once everybody cleared out
they'd take him back in the kitchen and
hook him up with what he really wanted
and then there's kind of a bittersweet
story there where she prepares what
would be his last meal right so the day
that he dies he is sitting for a
portrait and Daisy Bonner had a cheese
souffle time to be served at 1:15 FDR
has his cerebral hemorrhage at 112 so
the the souffle never gets served but
what she recounts is a true miracle if
anybody here has ever made a souffle
what happens if you let that souffle sit
around for a while it falls right ladies
and gentlemen I'm going to tell you
about a miracle
[Laughter]
Daisy Bonner says that that souffle did
not fall until three hours later when
the president was pronounced dead that's
what she says and she was sold it was
keeping hope alive that way was holding
out that it would be consumed by him
after all and she was so moved by his
death that she wrote on the wall in
pencil Daisy Bonner cooked first and
last meal for President Roosevelt and if
you go to the cottage to
stay it's actually preserved and behind
some plastic and she's the one who
actually calls the White House
switchboard to notify them of her of his
death so very very interesting for she
got him hooked on southern food and she
got him hooked on pigs feet yeah that's
another one falling off the great would
eat pigs feet
the way he liked it the way she made it
is she would broil them and then butter
them what yes if there's not enough fat
content I know it I know so check this
out we know from a one-story that he
actually serves pigs feet in the White
House yes not just to anybody but the
British Prime Minister Winston Churchill
he serves sweet-and-sour pig's feet to
Winston Churchill Winston Churchill
takes one bite in FDR who loves this
dish he says how do you like it and
evidently a Churchill was not feeling it
and he says it's interesting it has a
slimy texture and after I was like Oh
wonderful well you'll love them fried
[Laughter]
kershel says I don't think I would like
them fried and they both just really
crack up laughing but just to show how
much he loved hogs pigs feet if you go
to Warm Springs Georgia they have a case
that has preserved the shopping list for
the last week of his life and on that
shopping list is for hogs feet so he had
the proof yeah he had the feet of the
fever yeah I was gonna say something
else but it's kind of nasty yeah okay
don't okay how we doing on time I don't
know you're the moderator let me explain
this there's this presidential pickle
thing because you're probably wondering
what is the presidential pickle cuz I
did not come across that detail okay so
the presidential pickle is my metaphor
for how we deal with presidents and food
because we want our presidents to be
extraordinary people but we want them
also to be a lot like us and food is
often a sense gives us a sense of
whether they have the common touch or
not so that picture is actually a
kool-aid pickle y'all know sausage look
seneschal Cabasa yeah well sometimes a
pickle is just a pickle you know that
right but it's red yeah well this is a
kool-aid pickle does anybody know about
Kula khals okay if you don't know a
cherry if you don't know about Kula
khals here's the here's the we got a
shout-out back here yeah so here's how
you make a cool a pickle you get a jar
I've already made dill pickles take out
the top take the pickles out you make
kool-aid with the pickle juice are you
all right just hang stay with me stay
with me all right
then you poke holes in the pickle or you
slice them cut them you put them back in
the jar leave them there for two weeks
take them out and eat them if you like
the taste of pickles and of kool-aid
it's just a sweet and sour combination
if you don't like either one this is one
of the nastiest things you'll put in
your mouth like them so I just think
it's a great metaphor because it's a
fascinating thing it's kind of weird it
may discuss to us you may endear us but
I think that kind of gets us to how we
feel about the presidency sometimes
right yeah it's interesting you left off
that'll be a nice segue maybe we'll come
back to some other stuff but you know
it's Presidents week yeah this book just
came out lots of news lots of stuff and
you did leave off on 44 that did because
I finished the book before the elections
are you glad I mean this was a lot this
is interesting how and I'm also curious
did you get a sense when you were
researching this the the legacy I know
that in the early years the first
century and a half that a lot of these
people are the you know their
grandparents and great-grandparents and
you know descendants of slaves who are
working in the White House from day one
did you get a sense of whether or not
still to this day there are any legacy
families connected in any way to the
different staff positions no most of the
legacy families are really kind of
disappear in the 70s and
80s and 90s so in terms of the White
House kitchen for the most part the head
cook position it only becomes the White
House executive chef in 1961 because
Jacqueline Kennedy creates that before
they were called head cook her first
first cook they were pretty much the
dominated by african-american women but
when Jacqueline Kennedy says I want
European food by European trained chefs
the african-american cooks in the
kitchen didn't have that expertise and
that special specialized some of the
techniques passed down right I mean even
like and the Lewis who comes a little
bit around that same time the ones in
the kitchen did they hadn't gone through
that training I guess that's assumed and
so they start to just win all out over
time
zephyr right the woman i talked about
was really the last african-american to
lead the White House kitchen and she was
an interim White House chef because
Renee verdone who was hired by the
Kennedys just could not handle it
anymore under the Johnson's because here
you had this French chef yeah president
right so now Johnson would ask them to
make nachos and you've heard of chili
con queso the cheese he called a chili
concrete yeah it's a lot of tension and
so in that transition while he was
looking for another chef she runs the
kitchen and manages to get a raise while
she does it but the since then only
other person offered the job was Patrick
Clark right very well-known late Patrick
Clark very well-known chef here in New
York City he was working at the
hay-adams hotel across from the White
House and he didn't know it but he was
auditioning for the job because the
Clintons would come over there and eat
and other staffers so he gets offered
the job but he turns it down because it
was too much of a pay cut he was making
a couple hundred thousand at the hotel
and at that time the White House job for
Executive Chef was around 58,000
something like that yeah he had four
kids you know it was easy math yeah the
whole math and money thing is really
fascinating to how different
administration's and different
presidencies that you write about here
you know try to present an image of you
know thrift and economy like they're not
wasting the taxpayers dollars and the
extent to which they even early you
you know the whole big brouhaha with
with Washington and Francis and and then
they're people like Thomas Jefferson who
were like whatever I'm flying in a pasta
machine from Italy I am you know who
just go all out and are very extravagant
but the reason I asked oh well I was
gonna say most people don't know this
but before President Truman presidents
had to pay for their staff entertaining
food out of their own pocket and it was
only in fact that difficult cuz they
were often in wealthy wealthy yes but in
the winds of waves the ones who weren't
wealthy were very creative for instance
Abraham Lincoln and Ulysses Grant would
do their shopping at the army commissary
so rather than getting stuff at the
market to just kind of make ends meet
yeah and the whole thing about when they
shop openly or you know on the deal at
the market you know but the reason I
asked about the staff and the legacy cuz
I heard I heard that I don't know if
this is real news or fake news but I
heard that
POTUS 45 fired every fire the entire
staff people who you know had history
there and then he can I can't turn the
light they don't have internal lights on
cuz they fired everybody who had
continuity real news fake news anybody
know I think that's alternative news
because I have not heard that I think
what's happening right now is because
they haven't actually hired anybody yet
you have holdovers from the Obama
administration cooking in the kitchen so
you know there are three African
Americans who were on staff as assistant
chefs so they're probably still in the
kitchen it's hard because no one's
commenting so we don't really know
what's going on but Christian any moles
you don't have any insiders outside
looking in yeah but christeta comma Ford
who was a Filipina she got the job as a
White House executive chef
during george w bush's second term and
she cooked throughout the entire two
terms of president obama so
she's as far as I know she's still in
that position I want to make sure we do
have enough time for Q&A so if novella
could let me know when we want to start
that give me a signal or maybe you can
but I do want to talk about before we
wrap up do you want to talk about the
Obamas so the Obama is a very
interesting
with the garden and the push for healthy
eating there's definitely what's
interesting about them is that they've
they were a couple that actually ate
outside the White House quite a bit and
supported the restaurants thing so
people ask me what happens when the
president goes to eat outside the White
House
meaning not like alfresco with a picnic
blanket you mean like a restaurant and a
place okay that would have been romantic
mm-hmm so what they do is the the Secret
Service goes and they secure the kitchen
of the restaurant and they get the
security number social security numbers
of everyone there and now it kidding no
they do you have to make sure that
everybody can be there and then no one
else can come in the kitchen after that
and then the interesting thing is that
reportedly there is a trained chef on
the Secret Service who stands behind
whoever's preparing the president's food
make sure no cyanide gets right and
they're armed while they're doing oh my
gosh yeah so you know if you watch Top
Chef and they talk about an elimination
challenge I don't think it'd be
president dining out right yeah yeah
which I could probably do with the
current person talk about there's one
other funny story I'd like to share so
you know a lot of these cooks and people
involved in food service they're there
to make the president comfortable and
the one of my favorite stories involves
a guy named Alonzo fields and you've
seen him rolling through the slides
Alonzo fields was a longtime Butler who
becomes maitre d and during the Truman
administration in Eisenhower the maitre
d actually kind of runs a lot of stuff
in the White House is responsible for a
lot of the food so the Truman's love to
have a cocktail hour before they ate
dinner and their favorite cocktail was
an old fashioned if you know about an
old fashioned it's essentially bourbon
and rye whiskey with the simple syrup of
sugar and water some bitters and it's
usually garnished with some kind of
citrus usually an orange peel so the
first night that best the Truman's asked
for these old fashions Alonzo filled
with a lot of pride makes this
old-fashioned and brings it best Truman
takes one sip and she says well could
you
that's a little dryer we're just not
used to our old fashions being so sweet
feels like alright next night he you
know reconfigures the formula makes the
drink serves it best Truman takes one
sip she said this tastes like fruit
punch so he was a little hurt so the
next night he decides to just serve
straight bourbon on the rocks yeah Bess
Truman takes one sip and says that's how
we like our old fashioned hey I know I
mean that's another thing I love about
this book it's you know there's there's
a lot of stories about the people and
the food and some of these recipes are
slamming I don't know about that
presidential pickle but but the that MIT
pea soup for example I mean I don't even
like mint unless it's you know in a gum
or toothpaste but like that recipe it
was like the bomb I actually tried that
so yeah that is a Laura Bush favorite
and if you go to the Presidential
Library for the bushes in Dallas Texas
it's actually on the menu at the
restaurant there it's really good it's
very it's a great recipe mm-hmm gosh
there's so much stuff you guys so I
think that there's gonna be a time did
you guys already have a chance to see
the book go to the book shop or that's
gonna happen after this I think but I
highly recommend it because it's really
a great read and a great way to learn
just learn stuff that that really is so
sparsely documented I mean you talked
about you talked about that and you know
our involvement with the Hemings
foundation we're talking about somebody
from the most famous enslaved family in
American history and and still the
sparse amount of information no images
no pictures
he was literate you know where are all
the recipes and things he wrote down you
know when they destroyed where they lost
my hope though is that as the word gets
out about this book that African
American presidential chefs who were
very shy to share their story hmm will
realize they're part of this very rich
legacy and they will help share their
stories I'm gonna keep a website going
to chronicle this information and I'm
gonna keep having an active database of
people by administration because if you
look in the book I write down the names
we know of at least
african-americans who have worked for a
particular presidents and you'll see
that some administration's have a couple
names some have several and I hope to
just keep adding to that list so at
least that these people are known in
their may we know their names yeah I
mean it's so important so important and
that's why we established a foundation
and that's why there's so much synergy
between what we're doing and what you're
doing because yeah they are important
and they and they they sacrificed a lot
they contributed a lot they gave away a
lot they get no credit for a lot you
know and you talk about how some of
their recipes aren't documented but we
also have to remember books like the
Virginia housewife you know they're
documented by white authors and and you
know who are so we have to also you have
to be a detective sometimes to find you
know where these recipes still live on
right but in terms of the recipes and
just reputation of these cooks so for
the last 200 years has been this rivalry
between French cooking and magazines
around the world and French cooking was
set as the cooking of entertaining the
highest standard but often Americans
would come back and talk about southern
cooking and so often african-american
women were the face of American cooking
and when they were bragging about our
cooking that's that's who they brought
forth so that's why this woman named
Laura Dalek Johnson yes is very
important she's a free woman who
biracial who has to be talked into
working at the White House kitchen and
Benjamin Harrison does so because his
friend Theodore Roosevelt recommends
dolly Johnson and Theodore Roosevelt had
her food while he was traveling around
and had dinner at a guy named Colonel
Mason's place and dolly Johnson was to
cook for Colonel Mason so when Benjamin
Harrison becomes Harrison becomes
President Roosevelt recommends dolly
Johnson so she comes to work in the
White House kitchen only there was one
big problem
there was already a French woman who had
that job and this very French cook had a
very - very American responses she filed
a lawsuit right and she went to the
press so this is the first time that a
staffer sues the president it gets
resolved
and then she went in the press and just
talked about how poor the habit the
eating habits were for the Harrisons and
and other things but dolly Johnson gets
the job and she is celebrated in
headlines all across the country they
say her full name exactly and she is one
of the few examples of a cook who
actually leaves the White House and
trades on her own name
established a second career you don't
really see that a lot with African
American it sounds like they don't
disparage her as much with the whole
mammy you know you know I wish I I you
know I have I have a whole different
perspective on that yeah we took this
work but you know they they try to
disparage us and put us down through
things and it sounds like they actually
talked about her like a human being
somewhat because they dwell on her looks
a lot so you feel like it's been written
by a teenage boy some of the yeah but
yeah they do recognize her Manning much
more than they do others and so it's
interesting well definitely looking
forward to continuing the conversation
not tonight not right now
we're gonna let you guys ask some
questions and I move on with the rest of
the program but thank you so much
Adrian it's a blessing
[Applause]
so the question is how did I get the
recipes and did I test them no good and
confuse the microphones at the back of
the auditorium okay thank you I'll get
you next so it was a combination so I
actually reached out to several
presidential chefs and asked if I could
use their recipes a lot of these come
from looking at old cookbooks and old
newspapers and then some recipes I
actually called family members from the
President and just to see and I didn't
actually get a lot of recipes from them
but they pointed me in the right
direction to a printed recipe so for
instance I talked to Linda Bird Johnson
the Johnsons eldest daughter and the
strongest members remember she had of
Zephyr Wright's cooking was of the
popovers which is a quick bread and so I
included that recipe in the book so it's
really a mix what their two other
interesting recipes I have the state
dinner for Nelson Mandela that Patrick
Clarke actually devised but at the last
minute the Clinton said no you're not
cooking you're going to be an honored
guest here and so his assistants
actually made that meal but if you want
to recreate that meal which was a sesame
crusted halibut with some vegetables
with the red curry and lemongrass
dressing you can do that at home if you
buy my book oh yeah
another quick recipe I'll tell you about
is for a young lady named Kiana Farkas
who was Colorado's 2014 representative
to the kids state dinners that Michelle
Obama had so first lady Michelle Obama
if you don't know this she would have a
recipe contest and a winner was picked
from every state and the winning recipe
was it had to be a healthy recipe and
they would get to go to the White House
and actually eat some of the winning
entrees and stuff Keanu was definitely
the toughest interview to get in my book
because I used to date her mother and it
did not end well
well you must be the charmer because he
got the interview not only did you get
an interview there's a picture of her
next question my question is I was
wondering if you if you find out fine
found out stories of enslaved black
women trying to poison someone residents
so yeah the question y'all heard
questions so I'm just used to not having
the microphone so no I don't find any
examples in presidential cooking of the
enslaved cooks trying to poison the
president now this is a frequently asked
question is who is the official taste
tester for the president mic whip answer
is it's usually the president strongest
critic and I'm just kidding
it's actually the the chef the chef is
the last person to taste the food that's
put in front of the president so that
the that's an incentive not to poison it
something in here I mean you didn't go
into detail about it but you mentioned
something about leverage and how
different ways were protests and
different ways protests might show up
over the years and and I maybe I don't
know if you were joking but there was
something about poisoning and there I
mean there are stories not it doesn't go
into detail here and I don't think it's
relevant to the presidential you know to
our knowledge but you did mention that
well I talked about this story called
the what I call the poisoned people at
of 1776 and just really quickly the
story involving an enslaved woman yeah
yeah so the story goes is that Samuel
Francis his daughter Phoebe is cooking a
meal for General Washington at that time
and there was a guy named Thomas Hickey
was in Washington's Guard who wasn't
really feeling the revolution so he
distracts Phoebe while she's cooking and
he adds some extra seasoning to the peas
and the peas go out to General
Washington well Phoebe thinks that
something's going on so she goes to talk
to Frances her father and he immediately
understands what's happening and as the
story goes he bursts from the kitchen he
grabs the pay-to-play two peas before
Washington and take a bite
and throws them out of the why's about
the window and at that precise moment a
chicken was walking by Peck set the peas
and dies yeah so thanks for that animal
testing they figured out that the peas
were poisoned it's a great story but
probably not true because there was no
there wasn't anybody named Phoebe it may
have been a nickname but he had some
daughters but there wasn't anybody named
Phoebe and Thomas Hickey was hanging
that summer in New York but his crime
was counterfeiting not attention of
potential people isn't he right and
counterfeiting passes that would have
allowed unsavory characters to be near
Washington and might allow him to be
assassinated but if this story is true
ladies and gentlemen I submit to you
that is the first act of culinary
homeland security in our great nation
[Applause]
good evening I have a question ask you
is there anything during your research
that you found that was surprising to
you that you were that you thought you
knew and you were like wow this is
fascinating to speak on that I think the
thing that was surprising most
surprising is just the astounding
numbers of cooks that have been in the
White House kitchen or the presidential
kitchen I've my own research I've
uncovered a hundred and fifty and I know
that I'm scratching the surface because
there were a couple of fires in the
White House over the time so I think a
lot of records have been destroyed so
one is just that we've been there from
day one and a continued presence in all
these different ways and of course after
you think about it a little deeply or
like of course but the other part was
this civil rights advocate part I just
didn't know that people outside the
White House went to the cook to get to
the president I just thought that was
pretty fascinating thank you yeah thank
you hi I saw the Washington macaroni and
cheese dish on this morning of slides
yeah Jefferson hmm and I know that I
know I know that chef Ashe Bell talks a
lot about James Hemings having brought
back that recipe from his days in France
to what extent is that particular recipe
related to James Hemings and also to
what extent did you find the influence
of James Hemings throughout the cooking
that you examine great question so the
earliest recipe that we know for
macaroni and cheese actually goes back
to the 1300s there was a cookbook called
the form of curry that was printed in
1394 and that was the good go-to
cookbook for the royal courts of
Elizabeth the first and Richard the
second and the earliest versions of mac
and cheese was essentially the pasta
Parmesan cheese and maybe some butter so
over time cream and other elements get
at it so what we find in the book is the
old-school recipe which is probably what
Hemings made and no it wasn't close to
that he had several different minute
recipes or because of the culinary
training and because of the artistry of
it and the innovation so I think you
talked about also adding of the cream
and the butter and the extra cheese and
all of that yeah he he you know from our
research shows he wasn't maybe obsessive
about about testing recipes and doing
different versions of them and having
like ice cream is another one that he is
linked to the controversial ice cream
you know where does it originate but
without a doubt we know that Jefferson's
kitchen through James's cookery is one
of the reasons that it became so popular
eyes the macaroni and cheese and things
like ice cream and meringues as well
because Jefferson entertained so much
and it's just you know it just became
one of the early iconic it went from a
very high-end dish to becoming the
comfort food that we take for granted
today so another interesting story I put
in the book is that we know Jefferson
loved mac and cheese so much because he
actually serves it in the White House on
February 6 1802 and we know this because
one of the dinner guests wrote about it
in his diary he was a man named Manasseh
Cutler he was a reverend and a
representative to Congress from
Massachusetts and he sees this plate of
mac and cheese and he has no concept for
what this is he actually thought that
the pasta was a giant onions yeah so he
asked the guy next to him what is this
dish and the guy explains it to him and
that guy was Meriwether Lewis of Lewis
and Clark who was at that dinner and
then after the dinner Jefferson takes
them to the East Room of the White House
which was the largest room at that time
to look at the great cheese
when he was inaugurated some dairy
farmers sent him a ton of cheese
literally literally and it was just on
display so he would go look at the great
cheese was it moldy I mean it was moldy
yeah so when Andrew Jackson gets elected
there actually is a similar gift sent to
him and his it was sitting around for
months so he thought the best way to get
rid of it was just to open up the White
House serve some orange punch and let
people have all the cheese they wanted
and a horde showed up the White House
was toe up it cheese in the carpet and
in the curtains they said it smelled
like cheese for months it's the first
government cheese I like that yeah with
orange drink right should have been red
kool-aid oh but as you answer the second
part of your question so because and
Jefferson was teased about having this
half French half-finished aisle so the
fact that Hemmings gets this knowledge
and imparts it on others who would cook
for him I think shows the ongoing legacy
of kind of French cooking in the White
House and we have alternating presidents
there are some that are diggin French
food there are others who don't like
James Monroe big fan of French food well
his plantation was it was near I mean so
that's the other thing James is training
staff at Monticello but there's also
indication through our research that
when neighboring plantations are also
being influenced madison monroe the
different counties and so how that
spreads and how it even catches up with
the the chef that we all a lot people
some people know and don't know Edna
Lewis who comes to New York in the 1930s
and opens up a restaurant and there's a
huge influence on the revival and the
appreciation of America of Southern
cuisine so it's all a lot of dots
connected between this some French
training the recipes the things that
James brings back they say the ice cream
was more like a shake like a [ __ ] like a
you know but he finds out how to make it
firmer and you know and bakes it you
know puts it inside of baked pastry so
you have this older look yeah and so
just all these innovate really
innovative techniques that show up on
fine dining
sauron still to this day which there's a
link between the plantations and that so
yeah but this conversation between
French and American food and actually
drink wine is another way this plays out
and goes well into the 20th century the
Kennedys got a lot of flack for
Jacqueline Kennedy's insistence on
having the state dinner menus printed up
in French and serving French wines and
so they actually White House actually
has a strong policy of serving American
wines and other than and then LBJ takes
it to the next level he says not only
will we serve American wines at all our
state dinners but every embassy around
the world has to serve American wine
bourbon yes a and bourbon oh no I am
bourbon he was a yeah bourbon and branch
guy but the French had a very funny
reaction of this they were kind of
amused they just said well we understand
what Americans are doing there are some
fine American wines but all French wines
are great and we'll take this last
question Oh sir
Oh first of all wonderful presentation
by both you so thank you for that thank
you so two cookies since it's the last
one first is one our colleague Wade
Nobles argues that much of what goes
misunderstood in African culture occurs
because of our inability to understand
symbolism so in your opinion what does
food symbolize within the context of you
know the work you do and relatedly then
if music becomes the language of the
soul what is food yeah so I think food
is a great connector and a lot of my
work is really about how do we bring
different people together through food
but I think food symbolizes kind of a
world perspective you know if you have
someone who's an adventurous eater and
they're kind of curious they're usually
open to a lot of different perspectives
and other things if you have somebody
who's just eating the same food all the
time I think it is a window on the
personality of that person and so many
times we really don't get a sense for
who the president really is it's an
artificial image that's put out there
but when we get glimpses of how the
live what they like to eat what they
enjoy doing in their free time it gives
us a sense of whether that is someone we
relate to and we want presidents that
are relatable and presidents want to be
relatable because it reflects directly
on their public opinion polls and other
things and if they're unpopular they
can't really get their agenda agenda
enforced as well so there's this
conversation that feeds upon itself so I
think food is a critical part intended
right yes yeah and it's a connector I
mean if I had to pick a symbol for food
I feel like it's a connector and I think
you illustrate that here too a
connection between people who may seem
different presidents and their staff and
how they connect to a connection to our
selves in our culture today a connection
to the land the agricultural aspects of
it a connection to the past the history
to the future so it's a very connective
symbol so I hope we answered your
question and thank you for that question
thank you dear old dad so as we close
out this particular program I want to
remind you all that we are selling books
Adrian's books today and our book shop
and we also will have a book signing
following this so please give our well
our panelists a welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
have a good evening
you are still
[Applause]
here's a look at some authors recently
featured on book TVs afterwards our
weekly author interview program Council
on Foreign Relations president Richard
Haas explored the challenges facing u.s.
foreign policy author and journalist
Sofia Nelson reflected on the founding
fathers calls for a unified America the
parents of Trayvon Martin
Sybrina Fulton and Tracy Martin
discussed their son's life and death and
their experiences with the judicial
system in the coming weeks on afterwards
Lisa serve on will report on America's
bank and credit system and how it
affects the general public Rhode Island
senator Sheldon Whitehouse will offer
his thoughts on how legislative
decisions are influenced by private
businesses former chief of the New York
Police Department's Internal Affairs
Bureau Charles Campisi
will describe his work investigating
corruption in the police force and this
weekend Sylvia Tara discusses how our
bodies react to fat it's not just a
reserve of calories it's actually an
endocrine organ meaning that it actually
releases hormones that our body depends
on so amazingly our our brain size is
linked to fat there are people who have
the defective fat a genetic defect in
their fat and they're parts of the
brains that are smaller certainly mice
would have a genetic defect in fact they
have smaller brains as well our bone
strength is linked to fat our
reproductive systems are linked to fat
women if they get too low of a fat level
actually can't reproduce they don't
menstruate regularly even our immune
system you know so it's amazing that
there's so many systems in our body that
actually are linked to healthy fat
afterwards airs on book TV every
Saturday at 10:00 p.m. and Sunday at 9
p.m. Eastern you can watch all previous
afterwords programs on our website book
TV org
about twenty years ago I was doing some
research on my first book about
african-american women in the north and
I came across an advertisement for a
runaway an enslaved person who had run
from the president's house in
Philadelphia
it was May 1796 and I was you know sort
of caught up looking through microfilm
at old newspapers and but this made me
pause and I said wait who is this person
who ran away she was named Oney judge in
the advertisement I thought wait a
minute I don't know this person and that
was troubling to me because this is my
area of expertise I'm supposed to know
all of this stuff and I had no idea who
this Oney judge was and there was
something that was very sort of
compelling about this advertisement
never sort of escaped me and I said you
know I'm gonna come back to this
important story I'm going to try and
trace this woman I need answers so I
finished the first book and Here I am
many years later it was a lengthy
process in attempting to recover the
work of the life of ona judge this is
recovery work and for those of us who do
specifically african-american American
history doing this kind of work in
archives where the evidence is slim
factual evidence often doesn't exist
because people of color women in
particular often remain outside of the
archives and so what I will say is that
there's absolutely no way I could have
written this book had I not written my
first book so that's my plug for
graduate students and people who are
really doing the work of academics I
needed a grounding in order to be able
to write this book about a woman who is
really just absolutely magnificent when
you read this book you'll be blown away
by her life now many folks here in this
room and of course at Mount Vernon this
is no new story we know about own a
judge and you are among a small group of
people well actually now I hope there
many more who know her that's the the
expectation I want her name to become
one of those sort of household names
like a Frederick Douglas like a Harriet
Tubman because she runs away decades
before they do right so the title I'll
give you a sort of quick story about the
title never caught this was actually one
of my my first choices for the title of
the book and I presented it to some
people at the publishers and they hated
it and they said gives away the story
Erika I said yeah but so does 12 years
of slave
I mean honestly we understand right it
was 12 years it's going to end at some
point with never caught this is really a
hitch